let's stay in the state um josh allen is
here
balled out last night uh what was your
take away from his performance
uh against the 49ers you know what i
thought yesterday stayed in the division
yeah when i saw when i saw josh allen do
that against san francisco
and and i've seen him do this a lot uh
when he first started
his rookie year and it's it's funny how
maturity
will get you the benefit of the doubt
when people see what you're trying to do
they they understand what your game is
so
josh allen as a rookie when he would run
around
people would interpret that as he
doesn't know what he's doing he's out of
control
and he'd throw the ball and it would be
inaccurate oh he's never going to have
accuracy and look at his
his uh completion percentage his first
couple of years
yeah last night now he's in the top he
was running for percentage
when he was running outside the pocket
last night he was running around i said
oh san francisco's in trouble
he knows exactly what he wants to do
he's running around i said oh san
francisco's in trouble
he knows exactly what he wants to do
when he
runs it's amazing he may be
one of the best quarterbacks uh in the
league
and just when the play breaks down he
makes something out of it
consistently my question for you is
uh looking at his draft class
he was at number seven there was a guy
at number 32
who was the mvp last year lamar jackson
is it now lamar jackson's
he's already got an mvp josh allen does
not
is it is it fair to ask that question is
even a good question to ask
is he the best quarterback in this draft
class
because he didn't have an mvp that right
okay let me yeah let me go ahead and um
hmm let me go ahead and commend you my
friend
that's provocative gets the people going
that's provocative question you just
posed there michael very provocative
question
who would you rather have lamar
jackson or josh allen
right now wow
that is hard
that is really what's happened because
it's like i don't want to be a victim of
recency bias
look at those numbers he's a bona fide
mvp legit mvp candidate this year he was
chris cross
it's rogers and i probably put him third
right now i'll probably put josh allen
third right now
uh unless i'm missing somebody unless
there's a glaring omission
russell too many turnovers no russell's
yeah he's out of it
but no i don't want to marry too many
losses yeah
no i'm delaying it i don't want to cause
okay let me delay a little longer
all right let's go to the rest of the
class in the first round
it's not baker mayfield despite his
latest outing it's definitely not sam
darnold
it's for damn sure not josh rosen so
yeah that's lamar
and josh i don't think i'm missing
another am i oh well just to be sure
because you know we're live here are we
missing 2018
that's the first round are we missing
any other quarterbacks from that class
that i that i'm overlooking i'm just
trying to work in that conversation
somebody else
i don't think just at least deserve
mention as i continue to try to stall
before i just answer the question
you got to make a decision you got to
make a decision
just make a decision just make a
decision just making this
decision make a decision make a decision
ain't that what you told me
she told me yes you did yes you did yeah
she said we said
um we said we're gonna do that see cause
it's just like inside jokes
inside jokes nobody really understands
that jokes look man because i'm not
going to take me so long you know you
know what's taking me so long
i'm going to say what
it's okay because josh allen is so
good but bruh lamar
jackson was and and i'm sorry we ain't
that far removed from
him having a season unlike any
quarterback
in the history of this game
i refuse to believe that
he is regressing you won't talk about
carson winston making excuses for carson
wentz
and i'm sorry i don't mean there were
reasons not excuses there were reasons
you were talking about giving all the
reasons for carson wentz's regression
i mean lamar jackson's offensive line
has been decimated lamar jackson didn't
have any receivers to speak of
lamar jackson has questionable play
calling and game planning
bro there's never been a guy to play
this position
quite like lamar jackson okay in terms
of his athleticism
his speed he has some refinement to do
it in
in the pocket um but
so yeah and some growth there it is the
answer is lamar jackson your answer is
about that
josh allen is making it difficult he's
making it difficult that's why i stalled
because josh ellen is that dude
he is that dude no questions asked
but it's lamar jackson you asked me who
i rather have from the 2018 first round
draft class
is still lamar jackson josh allen's
there but it's lamar
all right this is a question this is
what this is why
you're hey listen that's why i'm here um
but you said it that you your
description
of lamar jackson makes the answer
josh allen why you said josh
you said lamar jackson had a season
unlike any we've seen
in the nfl now if he had done that
again this year if that's if he's gonna
if that's gonna be his standard well he
wins all day
but it was a season unlike any we've
seen because
i just don't think that's sustainable
what he did that what he did in 2019
is not sustainable you can't do that you
can't expect that anybody expecting that
myself anybody that's foolish no 36
touchdowns
six picks six ran for 12 and ran for
1200 yards
i mean they just did they can't talk
about video game you know what i love is
when you say it's video game numbers no
it's not
i've simulated enough seasons to know
that nobody does that on a video game
you don't you don't you don't throw that
many touchdown pass and throw for 3 000
yards and rush for 1200.
that's how impossible it was so i hear
you but
josh allen's growth and maturation not
only did were people too quick to
determine what he was coming out of
wyoming and what he was early in his
career
before he got incredible coaching in the
off-season from brian dabal and i think
even tony romo
had a hand in his uh mechanics
refinement
brandon being the general manager of the
bills
did a phenomenal job of surrounding him
with talent
nameless great job great job
so i love their talent overall i love
their talent on their roster
okay eric decosta and john harbaugh
you got work to do due for lamar jackson
what the bills just did for josh allen
i'm not saying lamar you got a couple
you got look marquis brown's good
mark andrew was good how many pro
bowlers they have last year baltimore
they had about 15 15 pro bowlers
position
i'm taking my skill position okay i'm
into my skill positions in particular
give him the system and the skill talent
the system in a supporting cast
that the bills went out of their way to
put around josh allen
and you may see more seasons like last
year's from lamar jackson
but if you put me on the spot what you
did which i appreciate i i can't
i can't say that the reigning mvp who's
just had a difficult season and look
some of it's on him i can't it's just
brilliant as josh allen has been right
now and i'm trying to
remove the recency bias because yes i'm
with you on josh i'm on the josh hype
train
i'm a believer i'm a believer but i i'm
sorry man
lamar lamar's the guy did i see a stat
last night did you see
did you uh did you watch the whole game
last night that's the whole game
or or parts of it in and out probably of
course
yeah come on sports we'll be doing
watches watching this i was watching
msnbc
that's the tv that's right go ahead that
is a tease i want to go there too
um but there was a stat last night that
he has
and i i want to triple check this
because i kept looking at us and that
can't be right
that he has never thrown an interception
in the red zone
oh really john chapman i was never
throwing an interception in the red zone
i
find it hard to wrestle did you find it
hard to believe
no because the first thing i thought
first thing i was telling if i was
coaching him is like
why force a pass we could probably run
it in yourself
or you know what i'm saying or the only
interception you go through in the red
zone is the one where somebody's
throwing it to you
you want to it's a triple threat he's a
triple threat he can run it he can throw
it and he can catch it
it was incredible um yeah
yeah but now i'm taking him i'm taking
him from that draft class
and i'm feeling pretty good about it
because i know i think lamar jackson
will continue
he'll continue to improve too i know
that but i know what i get from josh
allen i can get a season like this
i can get like three four or five more
seasons like this i know i can
hey thanks for watching brother from
another on youtube make sure you hit
subscribe before you leave and be sure
to watch us
three to five p.m eastern time on
peacock
appreciate you